tonight's guest has inspired millions of
young girls with her fantastic portrayal
of wonder woman
in her new national geographic series
impact
with gal gadot she profiles six
superheroes who just happen to be
real people thrilled to talk uh with
this
lovely woman please welcome gal gadot
how are you
i'm good thank you so much for having me
conan are you kidding
um yeah the natural when someone says
hey would you like to speak with
gal gadot the answer is yes it's always
yes
uh so nice to see you you look beautiful
as always
and congratulations i'm told that you
have a third child on the way
yes that is so exciting thank you it is
another girl oh wow okay all right so
that's
is that three girls three girls three
girls okay all right um i have
let's see i have two children it gets
confusing
i have two children with uh my wife and
after the second child i'm one of six
you know i've come from a big irish
family wow
so i thought we were gonna have a big
family and i said to my wife after the
second
child so what do you think six and she
said never touch me again
[Laughter]
we stopped it till this day yes you know
something occurred to me gal
that is interesting which is that you
have set a very high bar
uh when you think about it you're under
a lot of pressure
you have these you're gonna have three
girls in your life and their mother is
wonder woman you've set the bar very
high for yourself
you know what i did i set the bar very
low for myself
yes my children they think i'm a
ridiculous
person so if i finish a sentence
they think i'm a genius they expect you
to be wonder woman i would think uh i
don't know
you know maybe from the outside but but
when you leave
in reality i'm the annoying mom
that doesn't let them have enough screen
time
and says no all the time and i'm that
type of person to them it's not like i'm
wonder woman
right only where when there's friends
around
is that i'm still cool but we'll see how
long that's gonna last
yeah um but you know essentially we're
our children
parents we're nothing more it's true
yeah they
they if if anyone ever says something
complimentary to me on the street like i
really like your work
my children look at me like what are
they talking about
and i'll say okay maybe it's some work
you didn't see a long time ago
i want to talk to you about this this
project you've been working on which
i have a daughter who's 17 years old
and i see how influenced she is by
seeing
other and meeting and seeing other
really
impressive women how it it it shows her
that she can
accomplish anything and whenever i get a
chance i try to introduce her
to anybody i can a michelle obama
a you anyone who who my daughter can see
so that she knows she can accomplish
pretty much anything in this life
and impact this show that you're doing
is really a great idea
you're you're highlighting women
who are superheroes because
they live in the real world and they're
making themselves excellent examples
uh for young women out there how did
this idea come about
totally they walk their walk um so
for for a long time i mean after the
success of wonder woman and
fame and all of that i just felt like
super
privileged and grateful that i have such
a big access to people's life through
social media and
and all of that and i wanted to do
something meaningful with that and
something good
um so yuron my husband and i were
looking for the right project
for quite some time and when we
finally met ryan pallada who is a young
uh director uh who did a piece about
this
amazing brazilian ballet dancer from the
favelas in rio
we completely fell in love with her
story we fell in love with her with her
determination with her leadership
and with the fact that you know
even though she comes from such a
complicated background
um she has the force
and the ability and the want to change
and to
influence her her her
community and then we just decided okay
so we have an idea let's find
different type of stories that are
driven by
different women that will show their
impact in their communities and it was
such a
and then it all you know and then it all
became real
um but to me they're all super inspiring
because
you know it's women that went through
tough life right with violence or
discrimination or
poverty or trauma or oppression
or whatever it might be instead of
letting it bringing them down
they turned it into a strength they
let it fuel them into doing
something and and and try to better
their
world and it's so selflessness
and it's so beautiful and you know
whenever i speak to these women i'm like
you're the true hero it's not about me
i know people are we're gonna talk about
it and all it's you
you're the heroes you walk the walk i
read lines and i'm being hanged on wires
and
all of that yeah but you are true true
life heroes and i'm very grateful that
they let us share their stories
i think it's also to me what's important
is that
there are a lot of images there are a
lot of people
that are putting images out on instagram
that get a following because
of how they look and yeah
and i and i think that it's really great
to highlight
stories of people that have had an
experience
like an incredible experience or have
developed an amazing skill i think those
are great role models
for not just young women but young men
too but especially women need to see
that now so that it's not all
who's your favorite instagram influencer
you know
totally totally that there is something
meaningful there it's like
you know it's funny because now i do
this thing where i
ask my my daughter alma is nine and my
is four so mine is too small but alma
i would ask her what do you want to be
when you grow up right
or i'll ask the friends and you'll be
surprised by the amount of kids that
gonna say
famous yeah and then i'll go along with
it and say okay
famous for what and then it's like uh
uh you know then it gets confusing right
but i think
i think that you know i being a mother
and you know be coming from the
background that i
i came from and all of that being an
immigrant in america and all that
i want to be able to bring
meaningful stories to life i'm a big
believer in storytelling and i think
that
good stories has the power to change
um and i hope that people are going to
be
able to connect to it once they watch i
think they will we have a clip here
and this is i believe the ballet school
is that right yeah from brazil from
brazil let's take a look
at this clip from impact with gal
[Music]
okay
[Music]
space
i'm fascinated by one thing which is
that you are working with your husband
on this project now my wife and i we've
been married 19 years we have an
excellent relationship
we never work together we do separate
things
and so i'm very curious about this does
it if
if you're working with your spouse does
that ever get difficult
yes it gets difficult from time to time
yeah but i think we kind of
figured it out once we decided that it's
okay to to disagree
right okay um and from that moment
on it's kind of been
[Music]
super smooth uh but
you know for us it's just a different
there's all
different type of relationships yawn and
i are very
close and we're very um
you know we see eye to eye on most
things
and to be able to work with the person
that you trust the most and you love the
most and you
you know respect so much is the best
because he and i care for the same
things
um and it's kind of great you know
people have been telling me it's been so
hard with my
partner throughout yes i'm like
uh you know we've been living this way
for quite some time we're like
always together right um but it's been
it's been what was that what's fufu-fu
what's that
foo it's like uh it's like you do it
against
evil eye is it is it what's who it's
like from
from from like i think israeli police
jewish
or something fufu food food food
food knock on wood when you knock on
wood yeah
you say it's food food food food food
spit it's like
i spit i have to spit okay well that's
i'm i'll teach you anything you like
[Laughter]
okay well the last time you offered me
something i took you up on it
i flew about almost anything i flew up i
flew 12 000 miles
and uh and so don't say that to me gal
don't say whatever you like
because you can learn from my mistakes
yes you're gonna have to get up you know
you're now have to teach me uh hebrew
starting at like nine o'clock in the
morning
on sundays you know uh um i'll do it on
them on mondays
oh right okay monday give me the sunday
for myself hey
um i want to ask you something which is
i heard you were going to play
hedy lamarr in an upcoming apple series
and
i've heard that she's like one of them
she's one of the most fascinating people
in hollywood
a lot of people i think young people
today don't know who hedy lamarr
was and what a fascinating story
this is but i'm really glad you're
playing this part thank you so much this
is the part i'm super excited to play
and we've been working on it with apple
and it's
super exciting uh hedy lamarr is
basically
um you know a figure that got
lost and forgotten in the pages of
history
she was an immigrant a jewish immigrant
from austria that came to
america in the 30s and she became one of
the biggest hollywood stars
but at the same time she was at this
amazing inventor
who wanted to help speaking about impact
wanted to help
uh america uh while
they were fighting in world war ii so
she
and another composer uh had
invented this secret system of
communication
which is now basically the wi-fi and
bluetooth is all
based on that she never she got the
recognition for the invention
only when she was 80. she had a very
very interesting life story
and i can't wait to tell it no it's
really fascinating that
if someone if if someone didn't know if
i didn't know this was real
i would have said oh they're making that
up
one of the biggest most beautiful
hollywood stars
was also a tony stark level inventor
totally and and then was never given
credit for it
until very very late in life if someone
pitched that story
you'd say oh come on that's ridiculous
and it's all real it's a true story i
can't
i can't wait to see it thank you so much
yeah well listen i'm very excited for
you first of all
uh um on your third child
congratulations uh and i want to say
something in your own
in your own language what would i say uh
god be with you
god what's the best saying you can say
good luck
i thought you meant just say good luck
and i'm like go i know how to speak
english how do i say good luck
you can say okay so do you want me to
teach you how to say that
yeah good luck yeah please
that was thank you so much oh i thought
you just told me to get lost
never get lost
uh listen make sure i get the word out
impact with gal
gadot is currently available on nat
geo's youtube channel and i really
recommend this series
especially uh if you have a young person
in your life a young woman in your life
they should
see this it's really important and gal
really
uh you've always been very lovely to me
you're a really good person
thank you for always being so nice and
i've already forgotten what
i've already forgotten what you taught
me